we're going to look at a user database
computer kind of late 1970s early 80s
style but he's been knocked up with a
bit bold for a bit of fun this is
probably halfway between a zx81 of the
spectrum in terms of power and speed etc
so in theory you could actually wire
this up to a spectrum peripherals and
run a Sinclair printer off or whatever
from it so can we see manic miner at
some point in the future on a screen
like this dot for a little while my
board is here there's these at ATC for
you there's an 8k EEPROM body Microsoft
basic 32 cave web the clock it is said
to there the crystal for the clock along
with a few logic chips to select the
appropriate memory stuff reset button or
the end input/output serial chip the
talks down to effectively an Arduino
that runs the display at the keyboard
and then we got some input/output chips
for the dip switches little LED
7-segment display in a bar graph display
it's always from wires put into a bit
boldest you can see I just wanted to
play about with something old-school all
but almost everything there has been
donations to the nottingham tax base so
it's been a case of rummaging around see
what you can find it's not all there's
at ATC for you in that case I'll base
this order it's at 80
so yeah they really donations and spare
bits talking about that's that's pretty
much what it is you can find any program
which you could write it basic you could
write on it as well as reading input
switches setting LED outputs which in
theory you could then use that to run
relays be bigger switches control
powders or whatever or so you've got to
keyboard import and the little display
it'll be nice to have something a bit
larger but that could be next stage
there's a little program which obvious
and already any one which is familiar
with basically understand all of that
so we've won that's all you steady
counted up in binary on those two little
displays there this one is a lot
brighter than that one I could make this
one dimmer I can't make now on brighter
it's a program which will counted binary
on the bar graph display on the right as
well as intranet doubles on the
either by debase - you got the 1 2 4 8
16 32 64 and 1 to 8 nights so each one I
was at lights up for since that number
it is actually a 10 digit bar graph and
we've only got 8 digits of data so so
ignore the two that aren't coming on and
they won't ever come on
so once they're all full the program
alone yeah that's it
there you go all right so talkers you
how did that look in terms of basics you
have a look at the code itself there's
first four Lloyd's
last couple just to come to next at the
end the programmer fitted on the Arduino
controlling the screen is very rough and
ready it could be a lot more efficient
but it's not it does the job they're
your biggest matter it's also worth was
2030 Internet to try and find enough
information to build this there's
there's a great website by Claude CERN
which has got some schematics on it
which have a great help it's also got
the EEPROM breathe Microsoft basically
information as well so the link could be
down here somewhere it was pretty much
built up over the Christmas break a few
bits of tin cleared a few bits of added
or tweaking so yes a few weeks work but
I've learnt so much doing it that's
that's the key to me looks like a pretty
complicated it's kind of how do to two
reasonable extent the event wires at a
purple wires is basically you know
positive and II ground that's yeah
although the green wires are the address
bus so the CPU address bus goes off to
the web off to the Bob a bit of the
address bus goes off to the
communication chip there's 16 lines of
the address bus which means that the the
the CPU could address up to 64 K of
memory so if every every byte of that
memory has got the unique address within
those 16 lines you've also got the data
bus which is all the orange wires so the
obvious wires again goes from the CPU to
the form to the VAM communication chip
data bus also comes down to the i/o
chips as well so let's carry on a day to
either from the CPU to memory or from
the CPU to the i/o chips or back the
other way so it's it's an 8 bit
controller 8 bit micro as opposed to
you're born in computers which near 32
bit 64 bit once there's no hard storage
on this so once the power
your pho Graham's gone so you got it got
it type it all do it again from scratch
yeah the fairly quick to type in as long
as there's a short short program but I'm
not tempted anything more than about
7080 lines yet yes there's limitations
yeah but based little bit I was able to
find the your bar graph displays very
very dim conversely these seven-segment
LED is very very bright we've had to
turn out the lights to to be able to see
that do you know what all these
different bits came from so for instance
the LCD screen at the bottom there the
LCD screen is one of the few bits that I
bought on eBay the communications chip
up all as well which was most expensive
bit that was about six pound for the
first one which are there blew up so the
only one which had to buy they'd had to
buy a second one of it this is the
schematic of the computer here in the
middle here we've got the z80 CPU that's
connected via the address bus around to
the RAM and to the ROM this line goes
around here which is the green wires
I've got the Microsoft basic on the Bob
there also connects down to the serial
controller you've got the data bus that
goes round to the RAM and the bomb
they've got the a a ke raba Microsoft
basic on it I'm using a 32 k RAM chip
because that's what I had handy it goes
well to the communication chip up there
the your logic chips as well which
select the white addresses on the the
Robert of em so knows where it's talking
to and form and a little tyree circuit
over there which runs the clock for it
what's the next stage the keyboard and
display are quite quite modded by
comparison to everything else so or to
go a bit more old-school electro on
those I've got I've got I've got a
bigger display which I should be able to
see it a little bit more on that but
that's hopefully working and an
old-school Sinclair spectrum plus 2ei
keyboard this is probably halfway
between a zx81 of the spectrum in terms
of power and and speed etc if I could
get that talking directly to the memory
they'll cut out the Arduino side of
things which is a clutch
and could anybody do this do you think
if you could use Google you could find
the information and you could build it
yourself and you can pro I know you've
obviously had these kind of some of
these we've donated parts and stuff but
these things you can still get hold off
oh yes my odd expense if old computers
are the best source for these bits of
pieces about any old electronics or eBay
anywhere yeah